[Music]
but yeah next machina i yeah twin stick
shooter pretty frantic as you can see
from this gameplay right here this is
not even the least of how crazy it gets
but the music is fantastic music is
energetic like driving kind of half the
soundtrack spirit angers yeah oh and
this wasn't say o Bhima Tron or beam
Tron excuse me this is a job you a year
you're adding letters so what are you
what do you call the iconic settlement
in Zelda what do you call Kakariko
village nevermind he calls a karaoke
villager have fun sorry that's macula
you I have not gotten to be intron I've
not I place the first boss my I've
played the game for about an hour if
that I was using Jake's account on my PC
here umm did dude yeah we had a blast
with this game this is this is something
to look forward to honestly we had a
really fun time there like though yeah
the weapon types are great but it's it
looks I don't know it looks really
intimidating as far as the pacing and
like how much is going on but you are
very much in control and you are
consistently having these like
heart-stopping moments of just near
misses with like maybe those like orbs
or like there's one part in the stream
where was a giant boulder chasing us and
it was like I just member Jake being
like no way you're gonna make it it's
Raiders of the Lost Ark style just
screaming this is like oh it's just like
Rezo but you get into these tight
corners like there's no way I'm making
this out but then you use that uh
there's a - ability to correct three
charges before it recharges right yeah
can well yet it's there's a um there are
pickups you get and that's one of the
abilities yeah it's a three - yeah you
have one - which operates on cooldown
obviously but when you have three dashes
yeah you can chain three of them then
you get things like explosive - for you
uh you leave it explode when you land
from the - you leave in a explosion but
like we got to the last boss and the
thing about this came that the last boss
only came last boss of this three world
demo okay cuz this is a beta or a beta
is it public
um closed it's closed but oh my god the
last we're playing on easier normally
our normal and we could
and finish it and we tried then seeing
what hard was like and hard oh my god
it's every at like you start the game I
think the first enemy types don't have
any kind of uh projectile or I think
that every enemy has a projectile of a
little wave of those orbs is and it's
like it feels like the speed is cranked
up like double it's unreal on hardmode
which is a type of game you'd like to
see you know done like speed runs or
what-have-you the streaming I don't know
it this game is something look forward
to again the music is spectacular it's
one of these games where you just need
to kind of try it to really understand
like the the feel of it I did it just
doesn't look I mean it looks cool but I
think the the joy of just getting out of
these dire situations like you
eventually will have just like tons and
tons of enemies chasing you and all your
yeah it's it is stressful time on stress
I don't even I was gonna say it's very
oddly therapeutic for me yeah because
you get into this kind of flow state
that just you can kind of it's fun it
was funny watching you two on the stream
because you know you like I'm watching
you and you're like I don't know how
they're talking right now I think Jake's
playing right now but you do get into
this just trance and like when I'm
playing I'll play at lunch sometimes for
maybe ten minutes and I just it actually
relaxes me in a weird way yeah but it is
it can get stressful huh it kind of
reminds me of like I don't know cleaning
your room yeah where it's like you got
all this probs mess on the on the screen
you gotta get rid of it it's like just
gratifying blow it all up blow that [ __ ]
up if they ever low up my room to clean
it yeah if you go to a steam in like
three months
the house mark is gonna put that
pullquote on the game's page like
cleaning your room
Rob handler from GameSpot damn I haven't
seen some of these enemies those so
stacked razor blade things remind me of
the what's that enemy and Mario called
they're like those stacked spike balls
that you see in the desert area oh there
are like I accept these when you when
you destroy them they split up into
multiple those guys they'll split into
those things and leave like a trail of
orb yeah death even watching this is I'm
I'm so straight yeah but it's when these
things - were like the ending boss right
like we we got really close to beating
him and one of the things we realized
was like you want that triple - because
the ending boss is is shooting out so
many orbs at such high rate velocity
that like you just are constantly in
need of a dash and then if we have that
here's like a weapon upgrade you can get
you know - doubled and tripled here it's
just yeah it's just when you get those
pickups it's just fun and the other
aspect of this is that you'll see like
humans they're the green dudes there are
in each little stage here there are you
know four to three humans you want to
save and that will increase your score
and if you are going to be one of those
guys trying to get on the leaderboards
that's crucial you pick those and save
them and they're because they're getting
you have a certain amount of time
because they're getting like converted
and getting into these alien machines -
and pray right uh yeah it is very much
you know like house mark with resogun
proved they could take this very
somewhat simple idea and make it a very
tight game that's why I'm excited for
this Jake went to PAX East and then came
back like would not stop talking about
this game oh for sure I've never had
someone in this office I was sorry I've
never had someone in office come in and
like Jake of all people this looked like
a really charming guy just comes in he's
like you are playing this he said that
to beat you it's like I'm gonna make you
play like she kicked you out of your own
seat and is installing the game like
you're going yeah it was one of those
points in the year where what this was
March being PAX East I Thea early March
so there's what like everybody here has
been playing like twelve games here
they're all fantastic as the last thing
I needed was another game that he's like
well it's already installed on your PC
so play it was alright my recommendation
yeah should again this is a closed beta
people in the chat were saying they're
waiting for our keys so I don't maybe
they're sending more out there I don't
know but this will release in June right
around e3 I think or right after you
dream you can xx so right after the week
after e3 or something like that yeah so
this will be a good
PlayStation 4 and PC game to play no
longer just a Playstation because I
resogun was just PlayStation 4 exclusive
I believe it still is right I don't
think it ever came there was also a Vita
port okay um yeah I also some PC is I
also want to recommend you know you
can't hear the music here but if anyone
who is just curious about this game go
check out their trailer they have like a
really awesome like hand-drawn cinematic
trailer which is blasting this like
house like retro synth music next is
house marks Swedish there from there I
think they're from you know they're a
European developer but just when you
said house it reminded me of like
Swedish house house music that's where
house music started right sweetener this
is Sweden isn't a video of E cheese
Italian that's not house music eater I'm
sorry I'm butchering this whole
conversation no order I'm on like
episode 5 of master of none season 2 you
should watch it
yeah watch Messer another on the whole
day does it mean well like well isn't it
like a transitional thing like that oh
yeah anyway play retarget play next
month sorry
hey Blaine ex machina when you get a
chance June 20th that is $20 uh from
house mark the developer of resogun if
you play like that game you'll probably
be super interested in this game it's in
closed beta right now but yeah like Rob
said go check out our gameplay on
GameSpot you can hear the music you
gotta hear the music also there is local
co-op really not yeah the beta right now
no we weren't able to develop it wasn't
implementing it implemented yet as far
as what we played but it is coming to
what ps4 and PC mm-hmm yeah we've been
planning on PC
[Music]